the head of Valor Esports has come under
heavy criticism for calling the guard
slot in the BCT America's League a guest
slot his tweets also Drew him into an
argument with Ludwig about how Ryan has
handled valerian's tier 2 scene for many
in the community this is the straw that
broke the camel's back
[Music]
okay everyone before we get into all of
this just a quick reminder if you would
so please hit the like button the
Subscribe button and ring that
notification Bell cheers alright folks
buckle up for this one because we have
lots of twists and turns to cover not to
be a theater kid but this is basically a
play in 3x this past week the head of
Valor Esports Leo Korea tweeted about
the future of the tier 2 scene in
ballarine Esports he rather innocuously
shared a stay tuned message adding that
information would be coming in late
August we'll talk about that a little
bit later but Ludwig who has a whole ass
team in the tier 2 scene responded
saying please I'll run an offline tier 2
tournament also can we fix relegation
after the guard proves tier 2 is better
than many Tier 1 teams Leo's first tweet
regarding tier 2 concerns comes from
what he is addressing in the Tweet
growing frustration regarding the lack
of opportunity in and information by the
vcl which to Leo's credit he had been
addressing in replies to people if you
look at the responses to his first tweet
people are still anxious about the
future of the league and how it could
survive after all players aren't built
in a little Riot Factory and then
shipped off to each tier one League the
point of tier 2 is to provide
opportunities for growth and a path to
tier one it's the middle of the off
season pretty much and we still haven't
heard anything it makes it difficult for
Orcs to plan and for communities to stay
involved and informed so to hear in the
middle of the off season stay tuned
after it's felt like an info drought can
be disappointing and frustrating but
moving on Leo responds to Ludwig that'd
be hype indeed Ludwig X Tarik was dope
and I'm happy to support you doing more
let us know what you need his next
choice of words is we're all hell broke
loose and hey I'd love to see the card
winning the whole point of guest sloth
is seeing those Cinderella stories and
new team Pros making it all the way to
the top now hold on hold on there's
honestly a lot to unpack here but
specifically the wording of guest sloths
and new team slash Pros is what upset a
lot of people admittedly myself included
Beyond being a fan of the Guard the
wording didn't make it seem like Leo
believed in or understood the trials and
tribulations that the guard face
Northern skill level Beyond Myself
people were upset about the insinuation
of guard was new or even the wording of
guest but also morphed into this greater
criticism regarding Riot's handling of
the tier 2 scene after all this is the
team that has proven time and time again
that they are better than everyone
expects them to be an incredibly tough
conditions they've been to Masters
they've proven they can hang with the
best many including Valen himself felt
it was unfair to describe them as simply
guests or A Cinderella Story they are at
North America's Darlings we love and
adore them all of this was sort of the
straw that broke the camel's back the
lock information and clarification is a
lot but the guest slot wording game over
a good friend of mine foe I think
described it best when he said having a
very hard time processing what Riot has
conveyed about tier 2 valorant I can't
put to a tweet limit how disappointing
it is to see them disrespect their own
game by claiming partnership is the best
teams and players and simultaneously
devaluing the guard as guests evaluing
their success in Ascension and transably
disrespecting the rest of Ascension
shows the lack of understanding given to
their game but we are not done with
Leo's tweets yet everyone we have one
more Leo started off with okay we got to
the point where you folks will be mad no
matter what I say so this will be my
last note on the topic he basically goes
on to defend word choice the league and
Ascension program itself saying that no
matter what you call what the guard
qualified for it doesn't change the fact
that they are there for two years also
says very plainly that they will not be
changing anything to do with the
structure and system so we're sort of
double down in everything that he has
said so far and expanding on the idea
that this is how things are for the best
Ludwig responded with his thoughts
expressing his frustrations saying that
when this guard crushes VCT teams and
they're forced to descend because the
clock strikes midnight for Cinderella
it'll be incredibly silly I don't know
how to express how frustrating it is to
see in my opinion extremely valid
criticism given towards the head of
Esports and what he has said sort of
flippingly brushed aside by saying you
guys will be mad no matter what I say
because I'm going to defer back to Foe
on this one we won't be mad no matter
what you say we want concerns to be
heard and considered you make it sound
like they won't be reasonable humans
recognize the issue of sustainability
for your company in the same way that we
also recognize the issue of
sustainability for players what I want
to address is this topic that I kept
seeing pop-up of Leo is so communicative
and transparent we should be grateful
for that now we're scaring him away and
there are bigger fish to fry first off
doing the bare minimum of being
transparent and communicative does not
make you immune from criticism
benevolence does not give you a free
pass second word choice matters okay
intention does not negate Consequence
the information we currently have leads
me to believe that there is a large
disconnect between Riot and the
community about how we want this esport
to thrive we all want to see it succeed
but we have very different ideas of how
that needs to happen that being said
leofria hello my name is Elizabeth
marchini and I would like to officially
extend an invite to you to talk about
this live on stream here at the sport
Esports you've done it with plot chat
you've done it with the wise men I think
moments like these are critical to hear
from your mouth what is going on more
than just a tweet anyways my dear
audience what do you think about all
this do you think Leo's word choice
matters do you think there has been
enough information regarding tier two
what is your take on all of this until
then let's just wait until later this
month where hopefully we will get some
good news
I have lots of Pals in the tier 2 scene
and I really feel for them in moments
like these when a person who has been so
communicative in a person that has been
kind of a beacon for this community is
kind of flipping in his responses I
don't believe leofria is a bad person I
don't believe Leo Fria doesn't care for
what it's worth I think leofria needs to
care about the sport so it can Thrive
because it's his job I just think there
is like I said a large disconnect
between the community and I feel for my
friends in tier two who are kind of
dealing with the Run of this right now
because it's scary this is people's
livelihoods and jobs right like this
this isn't the Barbie house the whatever
the Barbie house is called in the movie
like this is livelihoods